el presidente de eeuu joe vaivén
inauguró oficialmente la novena cumbre
de las américas aquí en el centro de
convenciones de los ángeles empezó con
su discurso en la sesión plenaria de
jefes de estado y de gobierno aquí
presentes en su primer discurso ante los
jefes de estado del mandatario
estadounidense como anfitrión dio a
conocer la que espera sea la resolución
de esta novena cumbre de las américas la
resolución de los ángeles y delineó
algunos de los planes que espera que
incluyan entre ellos está el plan de
protección para futuras pandemias un
plan para generar empleo en las américas
a través de la inversión estadounidense
un plan para las américas democráticas
este plan es uno de los más esperados
que se dé a conocer los detalles que
anunció serán publicados el día de
mañana cuando se conozca esta resolución
final
el presidente dijo sin embargo que este
plan para unas américas democráticas
debe mantener y preservar el respeto de
los derechos humanos en las naciones que
lo integran y asimismo respetar el
estado de y finalmente el presidente joe
biden concluyó diciendo que las américas
ha sido y siempre será una prioridad
para su gobierno